as you might imagine world war 1 was one
of the bloodiest events in frankly all
of human history and I was thinking
about putting some pictures here and I
encourage you to do a web search for for
actual photographs from Rober one of
mass graves and people starving and and
and soldiers dead in trenches and it'll
will make you feel ill and and it's
probably a good thing to look for those
images because it will remind you how
disgusting and gross and of crazy
wars can be it sometimes we abstract it
when we look at it in hindsight and we
just talk about the numbers but World
War one was gruesome especially because
this was the first time that
industrialized weapons were really put
to use in a war context so there was far
more bloodshed than I think any of the
fighting powers actually believed there
would be but just to put things into
numbers and these are huge numbers and
these are frankly abstract numbers
numbers that are hard for us to
comprehend and we don't know the exact
numbers as you can imagine there's it's
not easy to take a census the military's
have a better count of who might have
been killed or who might be missing but
the civilian casualties are almost
impossible to count you have people who
are inadvertently killed by a bomb you
have people who are dying of starvation
who are dying due to famine so these are
very hard numbers to count but there is
some consensus on the rough estimates on
the total casualties in World War one
and in particular I'm going to focus
here on the debts when people talk about
casualties that often will also talk
about injured but just the debts alone
the estimates I've seen and I encourage
you to look up your own and try to
figure out what what consensus you could
get to but the estimates I've seen have
on the order of 16 million million
deaths during or due to World War one
and if we were to break down those debts
we have eight to ten million in the
military so directly military these are
debts of soldiers so this is the
military and it was roughly based on the
accounts that I've seen about sixty
percent of these of these debts were
amongst the on tante and about 40
percent were amongst the central powers
but neither case we're talking about
millions on either side of World War one
and then the rest if we're talking on
the order of about six to seven million
worth civilians
six to seven million civilians and the
estimates I've seen were about a
million-plus that were directly due to
military action so this is military
action impacting civilians and this was
disproportionately felt on the on the
side of the on tante on the side of the
Allies and that's if you look at where
especially the Western Front was fought
it becomes clear and also much of where
the Eastern Front was fought it was
fought the Eastern Front a lot of it was
fought on Russian land or what was
controlled by the Russian Empire at the
time and on the Western Front much of
the or most of the battle was in France
and in Belgium and also in Italy that
was also where you had a significant
amount of the battle actually going on
so this is why the the the Allies the
aunt aunt felt a disproportionate number
of the Allied of the civilian that's
directly due to military casualties but
then on top of that the rest of the
civilian town this is what's frankly
very hard to get an exact number on this
would be due to famine starvation
disease disease we've talked before
about the the blockade of the Central
Powers you had a major starve you had
definitely people not being able to kind
of eat properly
you had the Spanish flu I mean it was
just an all-around ugly situation and
then to make matters worse and this is
what kind of the history books often
forget you often had an explicit
extermination of people's trying to
happen during World War one in fact the
the I guess most notable but often
forgotten was the Armenian Genocide so
there was actually in a an explicit
campaign on the part of the on the part
of the Ottomans and this actually
started before World War one but it kind
of hit full pace during World War one
where one - I've seen estimates of 1
million to one and a half million
Armenians were systematically I mean I'm
talking about
men women children systematically killed
by the Ottoman government so war is ugly
and it brings out the worst in people
and you see it just from these numbers
and just to give a context of all this
is and it you know
it it's it's it's it's very easy for us
to just abstract these things but I
really wanted to sit in how horrible
this was but just to kind of bring it
all into into into focus this right here
is a passage from the Atlantic Monthly
volume 129 that was published in 1922
and it's a passage on Joseph Tamil tees
book Joseph Tamil tea was the private
secretary was now called the chief of
staff of President Woodrow Wilson and so
this is about his account of of being
with Woodrow Wilson after the war was
declared in World War one and it's
fascinating because it's it applies
frankly to to most Wars or all Wars so
the war president and the war at the
time of delivering his far echoed war
message in April 1917 the president was
cheered by dense multitudes thronging
the streets as he passed from the White
House to the Capitol and back again this
is from tumult EES that's that's Woodrow
Wilson's chief of staff or was called
private secretary then this is from
Tamil T's own description of the return
for a while he and we're talking about
Woodrow Wilson for a while he sat silent
and pale in the Cabinet Room at last he
said think what it was they were
applauding my message today was a
message of death for our young men how
strange it seems to applaud that